if we actually rewind to the beginning
of our conversation we talked about
uh you mentioned something I wanted to
return to so there's a there's layers
that are uh there's an emergent novelty
and you mentioned that we as human
beings and we introspect and our own
mind we really can't know most of it
um which of course makes me think of
this uh the unconscious mind the
subconscious mind uh and Carl Jung how
much is hiding there in the shadows
you've you've uh investigated a lot of
uh trauma how much is there in our mind
that's not directly accessible to us
like what can you say maybe
philosophically
about how much is there
uh lurking in the Union Shadow
I think there's a tremendous amount
there but I but I wouldn't I don't
immediately go to
an ominous perspective right because if
it's lurking there right it can come get
us right and and to some extent that's
true right because either the seeds of
Evil are there if we want to plant and
nurture them you think good things can't
lurk
but you're right you're absolutely right
and the youngin Shadow is supposed to
not just be dark things it's supposed to
be everything supposed to be a lot of
positive things as well yeah right which
I think brings us to self-knowledge to
truth whereas I think the the opposite
of Envy narcissism sociopathy I I do
think is all rooted in truth it's both
the truth so the good things about us or
the ways we're not we're not blameable
for the blameworthy for the things we're
blaming ourselves for ETC but the the
self-knowledge and the truth and and
getting away from the The Reflex of
anger frustration Envy shame what I
think happens then is all of that
underneath the surface if we look at
like the Consciousness is the top of the
iceberg you know outside the top say
well outside the water so is what's
underneath like shifting and it can pull
the top under right or is it supporting
the top and and it really I believe is
honesty truth self-knowledge humility
gratitude dude all this simple stuff
good mental health is always consistent
with Simplicity you know humility
gratitude are easy things to say like we
know what that is right we understand
what that is soothing Envy by having uh
immense power and subjugating others is
getting very very complicated right what
that is and how that plays out so if we
are in touch with ourselves If we're
honest with ourselves if we own what's
ours we don't try and own what's not
ours right what happens then is
something isn't waiting inside of us to
sort of jump us with some new uh fact of
self or challenge of self right then I
think what what happens are phenomena
like intrinsic learning like the way
that so much happens inside of us
automatically right how people who have
high levels of expertise know the answer
to complex questions more rapidly right
it doesn't take them longer to think
through it but they have more knowledge
to Think Through it's that more happens
rapidly and unconsciously so they know
the more complex Plex answer more
quickly and readily right and we can
build that in ourselves not just in
terms of factual knowledge but in terms
of how we respond to things right if if
I make a mistake do I respond with
reflexive shame right if I see someone
has something I'd like how do I respond
we're more in accord with ourselves and
then the automaticity in US is is
serving us better so that's in the
positive do you think do you draw some
wisdom from the the early pioneers
of psychotherapy like Freud and and
young yes that there's some repressed
uh there's some stuff to work through
that is in uh the unconscious mind
yes I think there's always like 100
percent
of the time if you have a living human
you have things to work through in the
unconscious mind right there's too much
that goes on around us that we might
find unacceptable and suppress right
there can be
smaller but important examples right
someone who
um
feels that they're not a good enough
parent and they I don't know they drop
the child's plate right and
um
and there's a feeling about that of
Badness in them that the person that
can't tolerate and pushes away right and
maybe they become a little bit less
confident a little bit less assertive
like those small examples are important
because they may be low valence but
there can be many many many many many
many of them right then you can look at
the opposite end of the spectrum where
someone for example feels or they have
to they're repressing their sexuality
right unconsciously something that is
so important to say to how a person
feels about themselves to whether they
can seek fulfillment to how they feel
about their ability to interact and
engage with others in ways that are
loving and generative over time so so
from smaller things that accumulate
often at a rapid Pace to really big
things we are pushing things into the
unconscious because they're not
acceptable and we need to explore like
why is that not accept maybe there's an
unacceptable urge because it's really
not acceptable to me right like a
violent urge maybe there's an
unacceptable urge because I'm actually
listening to the LIE Society is telling
me about what's okay and what's not okay
right so in exploring those things yes
we become happier and healthier and that
could mean if we're already happier and
happy and healthy it gets better we get
more insulated against the negative or
it can mean the person who's really
nurturing some of those seeds of of evil
and envy does that less or steps away
from it so whether it's good or it's bad
it's it's in there inside of us and we
benefit from understanding that idea of
the observing ego right like I said the
part that can stop and say hey this is
what's this is what I see what's going
on in me